knowing
knowing what I know now what I would I
go back and would I recommend people to
go back
[Music]
hello everybody my name is Naya and I'm
the black female engineer I provide
content for you and aspiring software
engineers and today's topic is going to
be coding boot camps I went to a coding
boot camp back in 2020 in the midst
myth of the pandemic I went from June of
2020 to October of 2020 and I went to
one of the big ones I went to flatiron
school I went to flat iron school for
what what four months
I think it was advertised as like a 15
week 16 week program so right around the
four month range and through that time I
learned about JavaScript I learned about
Ruby Ruby on Rails and JavaScript
framework react those are really the
four I wanna right yeah those were
really the four things we focused on
throughout my time at boot camp at the
end of it all I graduated with a job I
actually graduated with a job which was
insane and like absurd but the day of
graduation was when I received my first
job offers not the job I ended up taking
but it was an offer and I ended up
accepting a six-figure offer by the end
of October so about three three and a
half weeks after graduation which is
really really amazing and so knowing all
of this with this summary I just gave
you you may be thinking like okay yeah
she obviously endorses boot camps and
because look I heard that's how she
succeeded and that's how she got to
where she is now because right now I
work for a Fortune 50 company as a
software engineer and isn't really great
I really have been enjoying my time here
however
knowing
knowing what I know now knowing what I
know about boot camps knowing what I
know about what it takes to get a job as
a software engineer or as an entry-level
you know Junior because yeah I'm very
into level let's make that clear as
entry-level developer and whatnot
knowing what I know now about this
migration into Tech
would I would I go back and would I
recommend people go back
I think that I think this is so hard for
me to talk about and say because
I don't ever want to regret things you
know that's not a fun feeling regretting
an experience regretting
a decision that's not fun because what
am I gonna do now what am I supposed to
do now just sit in it you know
but I guess the answer to that is what I
do now is use it for the future or use
it to help other people and share my
experience and so that's what I'm doing
and that being said I would not go to a
Canon boot camp at least at the very
least I wouldn't go
to the one I went to
I I wouldn't go to the one I went to not
flat iron School specifically because I
really truly enjoyed my experience I
loved flat iron School however
one of the really hard things about
coding boot camps is how notorious they
are in providing different experiences
depending on the cohort you're in
depending on the location you're a part
of the size the resources like it's it
ends up being
pretty just inconsistent
and so for me what I'll say is it's not
that I wouldn't go to flat iron school
well it is but it's not what it is is I
wouldn't go to a paid or an expensive
coding boot camp knowing what I know now
when I made the decision to become a
software engineer I knew nothing about
how to do so without a degree
to me the only two options were get a
degree
or self-teach now at the time I had just
graduated with my degree in finance and
accounting literally graduated May of
2020 and joined up coding boot camp June
of 2020 the following month I found out
about coding boot camps around April and
it was the first time I had heard of an
option other than going back for a
four-year degree slash Masters or
self-teaching it's the first time I
heard of a third it was the third door
that I didn't know existed and so when I
did my research and I saw the top three
options pop up which were flat iron
School general assembly and a boot camp
part of like in my state like part of a
local State College I thought oh this
this is it is these top three especially
because when I looked it up it was like
yeah the best ones are these three and
whatnot and so those are the ones I
applied for those are the ones I
interviewed for those are the ones I
started choosing between between
I had no idea that there were free
options available I had no idea none no
no idea that they were free or low cost
options available maybe maybe with this
rise of people getting into the industry
without degrees and wanting coding
bookings more affordable options became
available in more
free and non-profit options became
available until maybe two years ago when
I was looking they weren't as you know
available maybe that's what it was but
I'm sitting here now and I'm looking at
all these options and I'm like damn I
wish I had done that now why is it that
I wish I had done that well first and
foremost you already know the cost
Flatiron School
cost for me at the time I want to say
eighteen thousand dollars I believe it
was like advertised as 15 but if you get
like a good job that offers a good
salary you pay back up to around yeah 18
000 back because I did an income share
agreement which meant I paid no money up
front they've now removed that and
that's honestly a conversation maybe for
a different day the whole Scandal around
income share agreements I think that's
why flat iron and other companies have
taken it away but yes I did an income
share agreement and so almost 20 grand
is a lot of money you don't think of it
at the moment because for me what I was
thinking was oh well if I get a good job
then of course I'll pay this money back
800 a month or whatever if I get a good
job like just give me the job you know
what I mean like I cared more about
getting the results I wanted so I was
like oh whatever it's fine kind of like
college when you're like oh let me take
out fifty thousand dollars in loans like
cool if I have a job after of course I'm
paying it back and it's fine you're not
truly thinking about the implications of
those financial decisions and maybe you
are if you're older I was 22 and I had
been writing that wave of
taking out a loan and then paying it
back for my four-year Institution for
the last four years and so to me that
was just what you did but now I'm on
this other side and I'm like Oh my
goodness
that's a lot of money that's a lot of
money and I knowing that there was a way
to avoid it I kicked myself for it to be
honest even if I have the job even if I
make a million dollars that that's still
a lot of money second reason I wouldn't
go to a big institution like that one is
because the reason I went to a coding
boot camp in the first place was because
I simply needed Direction it wasn't
because I couldn't teach myself the
material it wasn't because I didn't
think I could yeah do it on my own it
was because I simply needed direction
there's so much information out there
and that's kind of like part of the
point of this whole Channel there's so
much information out there how in the
world do you expect me to decipher all
of it to create major career decisions
you know and so I was like okay cool if
I go to a coding boot camp I will be
able to have a teacher somebody who
knows the industry guide me along this
path and say after you learn functions
then you learn and this and after you
learn JavaScript then you learned this
and I needed someone to guide me because
here I was self-teaching trying to teach
myself Ruby on Rails not knowing Any
Which Way what ruby was and what a
framework was and why those are
important and that's not good so I
really did want a teacher someone to
guide me that being said
I can get a teacher now for a lot
cheaper I can get a t-shirt now for
almost kind of like I also want to say
like free with the different courses
people have put out and the different
YouTube channels there are and whatnot
especially me who is the type of person
to if you tell me what to do you can you
don't need to be the one to teach me
I'll be the one to teach me I just need
to know what to do I'll look up
other teachers I'll look up resources
I'll read the articles I'll read the
textbooks I'll do all that is necessary
when I really want a goal when I really
have a goal in mind I'll do all that's
necessary just tell me hey look here
instead of here and I'll take it from
there and so for you to just say like
look here I can definitely find that at
least now in a lot of different places
places that I've even linked Below in my
bio that I've talked about on this
channel and so I wish
yeah I think what it is I wish I had
done more digging and more learning
about coding boot camps before making
the leap because to be honest I found
out about coloring boot camps and I
applied the next day and I accepted a
boot camp within like a week a lot of
people will say will a coding bootcamp
help me get a job
no it will not I'm here to tell you
right now I'm here to tell you right now
no it won't Corning boot camps will not
help you get the job coding bootcamps
will not get the job for you you truly
truly have to do it on your own just as
if you had gone so done self-teaching
and done the whole previous months and
years by yourself in my opinion the work
I put in to get a job was no less than
if I hadn't gone to a Korean boot camp
and I think it's that specific question
and that specific idea that's really
what pulls the trigger into making
people say okay I'll go to a coding boot
camp because they advertise hey 97 of
our graduates and everything get a job
within six months however what they're
not telling you is
of that night it's
97 of graduates however only 50 of
people graduated
that's how they get you and like that's
it sucks to say because again like I've
gone through a common boot camp and
again this is not like me bashing on
flat iron school or any other boot camp
this is not me doing that this is me
Sherry Howe knowing X Y and Z I would
have made different decisions I'm not
saying that boot camps are not
beneficial for some people however for
me I don't think I needed it and to me
boot camps are truly a last resort and
so when you see these headlines of 97
graduates get a job within three months
six months a year Etc they share that
with the masses ask them okay cool
what's your graduation rate and to be
even more specific what's your
graduation rate for like original class
and so like how do I explain this so me
at flat iron school there were three
cohorts happening at the same time a
cohort about two like sections chapters
slash phases ahead of us and uh and a
cohort about two phases under us I think
that's how it was said I think I think
of the people that I joined my boot camp
with that I entered with first date
these are the people these are my
classmates it's all of our first days
about half of us made it to graduation
day now that being said some of them
were yeah held back and everything and
maybe graduated later on however they
weren't part of like the Original
Graduation group and so when you look at
50 of those people graduated and then 94
of those people got a job then you maybe
want to say 50 or 60 of people
get a job within three months or six
months you know you know
I feel like like the devil is honestly
really in the details and Friday school
did have career services oh pretty much
all the big boot camps do have career
services that being said ah they didn't
do much for me and that being said
another one another layer of that I also
started
job hunting and everything before they
came into the mix and whatnot by the
time they were like hey it's time to
like review resumes and everything I was
like oh I actually have like three
interviews lined up but like I'll I'll
get back to you if like I need you but I
have spoken with like other people who
did boot camps and whatnot and they
echoed the same thing up no it's all on
you but like it really is all on you
they advertise the app resume help and
services and Market interviews and
whatnot but all of the things that they
help with that they yeah like help with
it's worth maybe like two or three hours
of your time and their time when you
really put it all together and I can
tell you right now job hunting took more
than two and three hours of my time so
what free slash low-cost boot camps are
available they're the ones that come to
mind are added developers or is it Ada
Developers
I don't remember 88 developers are added
developers that is a phenomenal one it's
free you have to apply it's for women
and gender non-conforming individuals
and I've heard really really amazing
things about their programs so there's
that there's resilient coders which I
believe is only available along the east
coast but I'll have to double check but
one that is available to really all
likes of life and in person and not not
even in person actually all virtual but
live and I hear it's amazing is a
hundred devs I believe it's run by a man
named Leon and I hear phenomenal things
about this man if you're watching you're
doing amazing I hear phenomenal things
about it and it's really just a man who
I believe is is an instructor for a big
coding boot camp but he puts in time and
effort and work into teaching you all
what it takes to be a developer and he
has actual cohorts and classes and
everything and do you apply and and all
that and it's completely free all the
ones mentioned are completely free
there's also going to be links in my bio
linking back to free slash low cost
coding bootcamps but yeah this is not
again a video to bash any big coding
bootcamp I went to one and again I loved
my experience I did I enjoyed my
experience I loved my teachers so much I
really really did however looking back
would I do it again
I think I would have loved to have done
the free slash low-cost ones and so yeah
I hope this was helpful now follow this
up with videos on really what to
consider when choosing a coding bootcamp
along with just questions to ask the
admissions teams and counselors and
everything before you sign on the dotted
line saying I'm going to become a
student so make sure you subscribe so
you don't miss those but yeah thank you
all so much for joining me what are your
thoughts what are you like yeah for your
thoughts for your questions let's chat
let's just yeah let's
this is Chad let's just have an honest
conversation okay okay all right thank
you all for joining me I'll talk to you
later bye